so it's movie review and time again yeah
this is going this is the hand from 1981
angel is this you know who who's in this
one Michael [ __ ] Kane Michael [ __ ]
gay
that's him yes right with his [ __ ]
Willy Wonka yeah he's plenty of room
where they walk I hear I don't think
he's part of the crustle sphere but I
thought everyone was part of the crustle
sphere no here we're going back on your
cress 11 yo G I don't know if this is
litter yeah there's a crossbow
connection and other than just me as an
observer observing my can probably find
across a lot like them both so I don't
think I can connect someone to the cross
the spirits they've been in a movie they
have been in a movie together right or
something exactly but this movie I have
to say okay this movie kind of
universally reviled when it came out but
I did too and like I saw it a lot it was
on HBO or Senta backs or something like
that like a shit-ton back in the early
80s yeah and when I was a kid I mean cuz
you know I won in 72 so I was about 10
years old in 1982 and uh I had a sort of
morbid fascination slash terror of
beheading and other types of
dismemberment right so if anything was
in a movie that had like that part with
the omen where David Warner gets his
head chopped off with a pane of glass
that [ __ ] freaked me out
and this movie the scene where Michael
Caine gets his hand cut off yeah
freaks me the [ __ ] out and to this day I
cannot hang my arm out of a car window
for this very reason because of this
movie and that scene it has just an
unreasonable amount of blood everywhere
he it looks like a giallo and it turns
out yes that's done that was done by an
Italian special effects guys yeah yeah
cuz they just loved the blood spray this
came out the same year that the shining
came out oliver still shining came out
80 right or late nineteen there's around
the same time but around this Santa
Santa Oliver Stone was yeah this is
Oliver Stone's second
movies first / major studio is wrong was
like an independent movie
Alvar Stalin was kind of depressed that
this movie got its ass kicked especially
up against you know the shiny I like
them both but the shining is definitely
a masterpiece The Shining is clearly one
you're gonna get your ass whipped
you better get chance to it by The
Shining yes yeah no shame in that one
but the stories are kind of similar in
terms of and a shine was about a writer
who couldn't write and the hand is about
a cartoonist who can't draw because he
lost his hand yeah yeah it's pretty cool
and he just goes insane he comes a bill
and if you think Michael Caine comes off
as a dick in the island or something
like this this is Michael Caine and his
Dickus of dick this is this is uber that
yeah this is just this is dick tastic
which evidently Michael cannon in in
real life is not a dick and coordinator
Hollander stone Michael Caine is like a
real gentleman to work with he's
extremely uh really cuz he he pretty
much always plays a total dick whistle
in every single movie he said exactly
maybe he's nicest like Alfred yeah he's
the best Alfred of all time yeah he
really is um no evidently he's he's very
cool on set and he's very professional
and he said that working himself up into
these rages for this movie said it
really took a toll on yes see that yeah
he does he looks really really mad in
there he was like yeah I don't know
what's a good way to talk about this
movie well okay the movie is actually
it's actually Oliver Stone were at the
screenplay like I said this was his
first movie for a major studio he had
done one previously I think it was
called seizure or seizures and it was a
similar theme of like an artist going
crazy and there's like ambiguity over
whether the [ __ ] is really happening or
it's all there Hatter's and
which is also present in the hand now
oliver's this is not an original
screenplay it was based on a novel coal
is a state called the lizard's tail by
Mark brand L and there's actually some
foreshadowing at the beginning of the
movie where Michael Caine's daughter
Lizzy who incidentally is the little
girl that played little Christina and
Mommy Dearest Joseph played Annie this
yes she played Annie that's what that's
what Oliver said really yeah she played
Annie in the movie Kanade yeah yeah but
she was definitely in Mommy Dearest like
as little Christina but yeah there's a
part in the beginning of the movie where
the cat has eaten a very large lizard
okay and the count was eating it and
then the tail was detached yes in this
worm and it was squirming there and I
was sitting there squirming and the
little kid was like poking at it with a
stick and the tail seemed to know when
the stings go and this stick was coming
it's like how does that happen daddy and
he's like it doesn't no no I was like oh
yeah yeah so yeah this is a very
unsettling movie it is and like I said
it atmospheric but it delivers it shows
yes it's weird and it surprised me that
it got like a lot of shitty reveal like
there was one review from the time that
was like really glowing that I found on
Rotten Tomatoes but in general I feel
like it was kind of really poorly
reviewed and I'm not really sure why
because I love the [ __ ] out of this I
mean it freaked me out a lot okay
because like I said dismemberment just
the thought of losing a body part and
then just like thinking of it just like
laying there in a field like with bugs
crawling all over I feel like they don't
like wig me out did the tail is also
pretty deep there's a lot of analogies a
lot of silly and there's a lot of
psychology going on yeah and really what
it's about it's about an older guy who's
like kind of like from the World War two
generation he's a real control freak and
he's married this much younger woman
who's from the seventies generation okay
and there's a big culture clash between
the two he's a control freak and she's
kind of one of these new agey
touchy-feely you know she's gonna be a
vegan you know and
he watched he loses his first of all
they don't have a good marriage to begin
with she's trying to split from him
yeah at the beginning she clearly wants
to run you and he does not want her to
they get into an argument in a car and
basically she accidentally causes a
traffic situation in which he loses his
hand yeah
and for a bit he uses that sympathy to
keep control over her yeah well to get
her to stay but he finally gets a
prosthetic hand and he tries to go back
to work but it turns out that there's
nothing he can do he's slowly being
replaced by Big Bite by by softer men in
society the the his wife is running off
with a yoga instructor who's a
instructor who's like this little skinny
new-agey type guy who's all sensitive
and listens to her and [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] that a macho man is not supposed to
do and then he then he's getting
replaced at his job with the comic strip
that he writes and he writes mandro and
mandro is basically Conan pretty much
yet and also the the guy that drew the
mandro strips for the movie actually did
work on Conan like trying it and it's
Oliver Stone at this time had written a
script for Conan Conan the Barbarian but
actually it went to John Milius and
isn't it first name is John right yeah
Milius to write Conan and that's honest
Swartz nigger's Conan so all of a stone
almost directed that Conan yeah but
somebody else got so there's kind of
like a Conan's fear going on here and
there's the reason being is because they
liked Conan Conan was primal kind of a
guy the author of Conan was a young guy
who was big into macho virtues but when
his mom died he killed himself
and really what get what stone is
talking about is that and I saw this a
lot you know I'm in my late 40s now and
the guys that were you know like of my
dad's generation in the World War two
generation you know like my
grandfather's generation these these
guys kind of
had a different way about themselves
they were really uptight straight lace
kind of control freaks they were kind of
afraid of showing any kind of softer
sides to themselves that they considered
that to be weakness you know or any kind
of self-reflection they were like we're
flames on the end of themselves and
right now and and and and Michael
Caine's character and this movies is
seeing a bunch of stuff that basically
points to that as his problem
so he has to go back to work and they've
hired a young guy to draw the comic
strip for him because he can no longer
draw and this guy also wanted to bring
mandro up to date so what does he do he
puts in a bunch of like you know New Age
ideas like reincarnation and mandro
using introspection and reflection you
know this sense that this sends like
what's Michael Caine's character's name
John John yeah this sends Jon Jon
Lansdale that's Caine's character sends
him over the edge
you know man and he he basically quits I
don't want to ruin too much about that
he quits and he takes up a job teaching
over in California way across the
country ways it starts in New York
that's in Vermont and then the wife
still wants to live in New York and
that's one of the sticking points yes
when she wants to live in New York he
wants to live out in California they're
very much opposites he's kind of he's
like an outdoorsy guy he likes to chop
wood he likes to live in cabins all
right she's a big city girl she wants to
live in you know old New York from the
80s in lofts and hang out with New Age
people really this whole movie I mean
it's a horror movie sort of yeah but
it's also kind of like a psychological
thriller family drama type of thing yeah
because it's one of those things where
the whole thing one it's metaphorical to
its left ambiguous as to what has to
whether it's like a horror movie or not
really because I mean I tend to think
that you know can I spoil it yeah well
sure you can you can game cuz you know I
tend to think that him seeing the hand
killing people because that's what
happens he lose your hand
accident they don't find it he has to
get a prosthetic and so he begins to
perceive that his hand is crawling
around on its own and doing things of
its own volition but really I think the
point of the movie is that it's him
doing them he's just trying to offload
the responsibility on to announce on to
an outside force because he is not
equipped to consider his own feelings or
consider his own rage why he's so angry
he puts everything outward he blamed
everyone else for his problems and that
metaphorically takes the form of this
hand that's going around killing people
that he doesn't like or that do things
to piss him off yeah you're basically
you're not sure whether or not this
guy's blacking out and strangling and
killing people who are kind of like the
focus of his rage or is there this
disembodied hand going out and killing
people or is this hand just a
representation of like psychic will
going out yeah killing people for it and
they basically in the end they kind of
tell you no he's actually doing this but
then they leave a bunch of like Oh some
plausible deniability there's a scene
where he is
being analyzed by a doctor who's doing
brain wave scans on him and his hand
comes out and kills that woman yeah
while he's strapped to a chair now he's
not totally free when it happens but
you're not really sure whether or not
you can trust but it's still high
cocaine yeah Michael Caine is a reliable
observer in this tale yeah you know did
he imagine that the hand killed her or
did he actually get loose and killer
yeah you're not really sure it could be
interpreted either way that's right and
and Oliver Stone said that that's the
way he wanted he wanted it to be kind of
ambiguous yeah was he doing the murder
himself or was that hand a psychic
embodiment of his head so in other words
kind of like telekinesis or power of the
dark side of the force or poultrygeist
basically you know like a poltergeist I
type
that leaves it up to you depending on
whatever interpretation you want to go
that you want to go with you know yeah
because I mean essentially this movie
and I'm gonna say - there have been a
couple other movies about kind of a
rogue body parts of this type obviously
one of my favorite ones is actually a
silent movie from the 1920s called the
hands of Orlac and if you go to my blog
which is goddess of hellfire comm and
search for hands of orluk i wrote like a
really big long breakdown of it but a
similar thing happens in that movie was
like a pianist so his livelihood is his
hands he's in a train accident both his
hands are cut off and then he gets what
he thinks are murderers hands stitched
onto his body and he begins to perceive
that they're acting of their own
volition that they are killing people he
would never do such a thing longer block
so it's a similar kind of theme here
it's like Michael Caine even from the
beginning of the movie is a raging
dickwad yeah he gets worse and he gets
what like as bad as he is at the
beginning he's just very he's very
dismissive of his wife he's just like
constantly like belittling like what she
wants to do and she clearly wants to
leave but he doesn't want her to right
not because it doesn't really seem he
doesn't want her to you know it's not
because he loves her so much and stuff
like that it's just he wants to control
he wants control over her he wants
control over the daughter and he's like
you know no one leaves me because I'm
the man I'm the boss he's kind of like
that so he won't let her go the you know
the main fight that kind of causes his
hand to get cut off it's her juicing
well I'm just going to go anyway right
which you know if she wants to go he
should have just said okay but he
doesn't want to do that he gets all
upset about it and you know they end up
getting an accident so the whole thing
about Michael Caine's kind of descent
into madness yeah is you know the reason
that it's a hand its loss of control his
hand he's a cartoonist so that's his
livelihood
and there are scenes in it where like
he's at dinner with his female editor
and she starts like cutting his meat and
in the restaurant like kind of his movie
gonna spoon and feet and feeding him and
stuff like that without asking him and
you can see on his face this kind of
like shame yeah that he has lost all
control yeah that he thought he
possessed and the hand obviously is a
penis metaphor the manhood metaphor too
and he specifically says that no there's
this is a really cool scene he's talking
to his buddy in a bar and basically tell
he tells his buddy that he thinks that
he's blacking out because he hung out
with us he hooked up with this chick
this is one night where the savings -
deuce have sex with her when and some
time he looked through her notebook and
he found a picture of her a really cool
picture her kind of like kneeling down
the inside of his hand and the quality
of the artwork was good it was like he
said that's the way he used to draw with
his right hand right how did he do that
and his buddy said well damn you know
you either blacked out and your
subconscious did that with your left
hand you know what I mean
or you somehow did it with micro
impulses through your prosthetic hand
well he says in and he says if I was you
I'd be scared of black announced
dangerous and he goes could you rape
somebody says that you could kill
somebody
yeah and the Michael Caine's John
character he takes the whole thing as a
negative because he responds to
everything negatively but Jenni and I
started analyzing it really what it what
I think the hand or the subconscious was
trying to tell him was that if he wanted
to he could draw just as well as he used
to either with his left hand or the
prosthetic hand and the hand the the
picture was symbolic the hand that's his
it or his power his phallic symbol or
you know a lot of his negative anger and
his force kind of possessing that woman
and talking about yeah that that that
was all and it was all drawn beautifully
so he could have what he wanted it was
in his subconscious yeah if he knew how
to access it but instead he chose the
the dark side he
more towards the dark side he chose to
join ger and violence and like I said
this is kind of like you know when he's
in Lexi when he's in the office with the
new cartoonist that's going to be
redrawing his his strip mandrel and you
know the new artist has kind of changed
it up a little bit made it a little more
modern more new agey stuff like that
more introspective as maybe there's a
more introspective yeah so Michael Caine
gets very very angry at this and says
specifically man drew doesn't think he
just does what he wants yeah he knows
what he wants he's just done he just
does it he doesn't think about it he's
not introspective at all and the new guy
looks like well man if we can give
another dimension to this character
it'll sell as good as Pogo to this Pogo
this isn't Pogo because but have you
seen sales on Pogo yeah you know it's
it's making a basically making a [ __ ] on
a money walked away from all that yeah
he says no I keep it's not his way if
it's not my way he acting irrationally
because he would not collaborate he
could not collaborate well because he
was so uptight and he couldn't adapt
gonna DAP could collaborate and this is
like you said that was a very pivotal
scene also the the scene where he finds
the beautiful drawing was also very
pivotal because like you said I think
that that was his subconscious as a last
last-ditch effort trying to say to him
look if you looked inside yourself if we
do act as you could do it you grow it
with your left hand right where you can
do with your prosthetic cousin because
shouldn't we teach yourself to drive it
with your other hand of course you can
yeah you just have to put the effort in
but he was not willing to do that so
that was like the tragedy that was this
last-ditch effort his last chance and he
pissed it away yeah and it's kind of the
whole thing's kind of an analogy for
kind of guys from the older generation
you always run and run into it as guys
get older some of them fail to adapt
they can't learn new tricks they want it
the way it used to be and now it's no
longer viable you know that people don't
want that anymore that doesn't sell well
in the market so really the whole movie
in a way is a warning to men it really
is yeah yeah yeah I think all men should
see this and analyze it it's in on how
not to
as a man it's of what they would
nowadays call toxic masculinity yeah
yeah and I'm really believing in that
kind of Airy fairy [ __ ] but I never
agree with you yeah that is toxic
masculinity yeah and not all men are
guilty of it but that's a good example
of it yeah there you see what happens
nowadays is you have people they have
certain people saying any kind of
masculinity is toxic that's not true
there is a positive masculine and
there's a positive strength too
this is a very negative strength and if
you haven't seen this flick go check
this out yeah and really just kind of
scratching the surface of the analysis
this is analysis slash tease and
contribute to this movie cuz this movie
actually was kind of big part of my
childhood I saw so many times I know I
see it right and I didn't really catch
all the angles because I wasn't really
old enough having gone back and see it
now I've watched it twice and then once
with all just a member third time with
Oliver Stone's commentary yeah he
watched and he confirmed some of the
suspicions I thought he was trying to
tell me yeah because um he said that he
had to remove if he didn't have total
control over this quick yes he had to
remove a couple of scenes and he had to
reshoot some stuff and he thought the
movie was a failure he'd liked the movie
but he thought it failed to get across
the message that he want that he wanted
to get across and it was what I
suspected he wanted it to be get more
across the ambiguity of was that hand
really there or not was that some kind
of a psychic force killing people and
the way it looks the way that final
scene is shot it looks too much like no
it was him doing it
stone wanted it to be about 50/50 that
no it could have been a psychic force
yeah that did that but yeah but like I
said the whole point of Michael Caine's
character and the whole kind of point
that Oliver Stone is making in this
movie and maybe it was made in the book
to I'm not really sure I'm not sure how
similar the book is to the screenplay
he said he realized some of the dialogue
he thought the dialogue was good in the
book and he included the best
from the book yeah in this movie he like
he stone was very satisfied with the
dialogue in the mood and I'd have to
agree yeah I think is fantastic
yeah and Kane yeah I mean he looks at
[ __ ] and this one you know I said kid
most of the Kings acting yes this dude
just looks and she just looks at Jimmy
he looks a lot of [ __ ] looks at [ __ ] and
you know if he's scared of it or you
know he's furious and I'll tell you this
guy was as a kid one of the first actors
this scared the [ __ ] out of me and he
wasn't in a mask or a costume just me
looking at Michael Caine's face as he
became evil he became a monster to me as
a kid just like yeah I have that now
[ __ ] scary looking yeah yeah cuz he
looked very frightening yeah when he
gets all when he gets his dander all up
yeah and then there's no there's no mask
or or or you know he just at the end he
just looks so [ __ ] evil he looks like
a Sith Lord and there's kind of a story
arc oh yeah I walk her know yeah and
that's why was talk about the psychic
force you know he says it's almost like
the dark side it's they're leaving
ambiguous it's awesome I think like I
think in a way it's a minor masterpiece
not as good as as The Shining but well
obviously but you know you know what
dollar for dollar it can hold its own
that's shining yeah like I said I'm Kai
I was always kind of confused about you
know why it didn't get good reviews and
stuff like that but like I said the
whole point that Oliver Stone was making
in this movie was that Michael Caine's
character became evil because he won he
was he refused to look inside himself
and see why he was so angry he all of
his anger was focused outward yeah and
the reason he wouldn't look inward is
because he was afraid
yeah and that fear he perceived as a
weakness so he had to push it down and
push it down which made him angrier and
it was just this fed into this loop and
they just got Bray Jarrod rage earnest
and then he just started it's kind of
reminds you of like basic training and
infantry AIT it was always at the
beginning at AIT it's always the tough
the guys who you think are the toughest
where was some of the first
crap that was because in those day of
pride you know when it yeah mostly these
really young tough guys don't know what
it's like to be really tired or really
exhausted or to feel really weak you
know cuz you're just so exhausted and
then their feelings of weakness get them
to give up they're not [ __ ] I'm out
of here
I can't take this I can't lower myself
to this and you know and it's because
most of the time through basic training
and advanced individual training for
like infantry it's guys trying to pull
themselves through the crucible so
they're not doing it on their own
they're kind of using teamwork to
survive and he wasn't the kind of guy
that you know this character from proud
of the hand is not the kind of guy to
use teamwork know he told you how you
want to have him right and that was such
failure to adapt and then you to adapt
failure to collaborate we were exactly
failure to listen to anyone elses ideas
and failure to understand your own
weaknesses happy-happy that won't make
them that was a because when you
understand your weaknesses you can you
can achieve endurance its endurance that
wins that strength I mean okay good
example look at Frank Castle from The
Punisher not only could he kill enemies
you could beat him to death basically
and he would just escape into a realm of
hint you know of visions of him making
out with his wife he could take endure
tremendous punishment you know me which
that's a good thing to have is this
probably even more than take a beat up
it's better to be able to get beat up
and endure and endure it and survive it
and come back that's kind of what
Daredevils categories like we can kick
people's asses too but he can get his
ass kicked and still keep growing so I
think that's kind of an underrated just
still from you know man-to-man for me
Tom do you guys listen and you know our
mechs mechs army what really makes a man
is not the ability to dish it out but
the ability to take it because it's
endurance that wins you know yeah like
the United States won its it won its
revolutionary war against England we
didn't win it really you need the big
battles just that we kissed kept
enduring they gave up yes that's how
that was
just warm out just well yeah Michael
Caine's character did not have endurance
yeah like I said you a lot of anger that
he unyielding on yeah and everything was
someone else's someone else's fault
right like I said he couldn't he never
admitted any of his own shortfalls yeah
and never couldn't roll it with his own
weaknesses and learn how to get around
them yeah you know so like here's the
thing like there's a scene like that's
kind of our baby's like a third of the
way into the movie or something like
that where he comes home early like
after he's had a little rage fit at one
of the meetings because you know his
strips getting taken over and his wife
is there with the yoga string they're
not [ __ ] or anything like that but
her and the yoga instructor like
counselling says I guess he's counseling
her so she's talking about her feelings
and there's a scene where Michael Caine
like looks in to the room and she turns
around and looks at him and she's crying
and that her face with the tears keeps
coming back to him yeah now had he taken
that and thought to himself hey maybe I
have been a douche maybe I should listen
to her feelings maybe I should let her
do what she wants to do maybe she
doesn't want to be with me or maybe you
know maybe this guy has something to
offer that I don't or something like
that and but the fact that he couldn't
do that he just got mad he got mad at
her he got mad at the yoga instructor
instead of thinking that maybe it was a
shortcoming of his that had driven her
away and it was kind of the same thing
with the drawing and like I said I think
that was the last that was his brains
last attempt and it's trying to get
through to him that if he didn't blame
other people if he got his anger under
control he could adapt with he could
learn to draw with his left hand for
example you know he could adapt to a new
situation but he would not do that and
that was his downfall the moral of the
story is be well-rounded yeah be
well-rounded understand your own
shortcomings and don't be so hard on
yourself yeah be innovative try new [ __ ]
don't be [ __ ] uptight but the cool
thing I mean okay and it'll kind of in
closing but like the cool thing about
this movie like I saw it a lot when I
was a kid and it scared me and you know
we recently saw it again and we just got
it on blu-ray and stuff like that and I
think I like it even more now now it has
that very ponderous slow pace that a lot
of horror movies back then had yeah but
I like that better this is it's honestly
it's kind of a horror movie but it's
kind of more like a psychological study
really with just kind of some horror
elements I said also as kind of like
something in the same vein as Conan
Conan was a guy who survived the
crucible and came out fantastic well
rounder warrior for his time this is a
guy that could not survive the crucible
became a murderer destroyed himself yeah
and really I mean how many movies are
you gonna see with Michael Caine with
blood spraying out of a stump on the
side of the road and just screaming his
[ __ ] head off it's awesome yeah blood
everywhere
any talk [ __ ] to dukkha talk [ __ ] yeah
yeah what's wrong with our marriage
is he [ __ ] you just go see the play
yeah it's very good and like exit that
you can see through there sometimes it
comes and goes it comes and goes on
Netflix and I think you can rent it on
YouTube I think we rented it on YouTube
a few years ago I had to buy it for my
DVD collection yeah they don't have this
on blu-ray as far as because this was
one of the formative movies of my dad
it was this one the shining time after
time which like I said we got to do one
on that My Bloody Valentine for some
reason that scared the [ __ ] outta me I
was a kid
terror train terror I can cast the
Canadian slasher it's fun house yeah
that's the bigger berth in the funhouse
nobody got me that guy freaked me out at
the beginning of nighttime he had the
best toys in the funhouse cuz he was
like creepy but he was also sounded like
boy slow and there was something really
area because sometimes people's voices
in movies freaked me out
yeah like I was always freaked out by by
Danny's spilling bread not so much him
just going bad round right brother but
when he goes and it's like what it was
like down here and then it went way up a
notch and I was like oh no oh no that
for some reason that scares me a lot and
to end funnily enough and this actually
kind of has a like back to the hand
because the guy that plays the younger
cartoonist Charles Fleischer I think his
name is was the same guy that did the
voice for Roger Rabbit and Who Framed
Roger Rabbit and there is a scene in Who
Framed Roger Rabbit where you find out
spoiler alert that Judge doom is a toon
and you thought he was a human this
whole time and so he's talking normally
and then his voice goes like that
freaked me the [ __ ] out one of the
things about this movie that I guess I
didn't I didn't realize why I liked it
but it always kind of hit a resonant
tone with me is that when Michael
Caine's character is up in the mountains
of the cabin for some reason that gave
me a feeling of like you know I mean I
got like a certain amount of connection
to those scenes yeah turns out it was
Big Bear Lake which you know my family
used to take me up there all the time
yeah California yeah anyway so if you
haven't seen it like I said if you like
Oliver Stone's other movies this is kind
of his first major studio one and you
can kind of see like a lot of his tropes
you can see his talent and stuff like
that like I said very poorly reviewed
even now but first there's nothing
some of the younger guys seem to like
yeah there's just something I really
like about it's got like a really creepy
kind of vibe and like Michael Caine it's
like some of the scenes are like yet or
like really overwrought at least Aires
the flick but yeah but he's very scary
yeah and the woman the woman who plays
his wife is excellent - it's good acting
all of it yeah there isn't anybody the
sockson no no there's not yeah they're
good it's a good movie yeah but yeah I
like it a lot so you know we recommend
it so tell us what you think of it down
in the comment section and we will be
back with another movie review some time
or another and our regular episode will
be up on Tuesday so we will see you
later bye